Vào các thông tin bà đầu, Bụ trái xảy ra vào khoảng 18,5 mấy mấy bởi tháng 17 tại công phía chức dẫn hiểu hạn sản xuất à tiên lời, phương tân khán thành phố Chí Minh.
Thưa điểm trên, mọi lửa bất ngờ bùng phát sử dội khiến người dân không thể khổ chế.
Lửa muy cơ trái lan xang nhà dân sách bên. Nhận tin báo, đổi chữa trái và kêu nạn kêu ộ khu vực 8,2, phòng cạnh sắp phòng trái chữa trái,
và kêu nạn kêu ộ khu ngăn thành phố Chí Minh đã điều bốn xe chữa trái và 20 mấy tư, cả 1 trình xí đến hình trường trường khai giập lượng.
Thè báo cao nhăn của đổi chữa trái và kêu nạn kêu ộ khu vực 8,2, nhận định tình hình trái phức tạm.
Đổi đã đề nghỉ chúng tâm chỉ vuy trị việc thêm xe chữa trái và cả 1 trình xí.
Tổng số xe chữa trái tham gia là 1 xe cũng tả 1 tư, cả 1 trình xí,
chỉ vuy và 1 xe chữa trái khu công nghiệp năng tình oyên.
Nó lửa xe đó đã được không chỉ không cho trái lan sàng nhà dân.
Vũ trái không kê thị thải vình người nhưng khiến nhà dự 1 nghìn mấy quân bị đồ sập.
Nguyên nhân và thị thải đang được công an thành phố Chí Minh được trái tham kê.